I mean was there a day that filmmaking
mattered to you more than skateboarding
there were some days where it did and
some days that didn't you know I think
so when I was 17 I I'd watched the film
slacker and I like I took the Freak
Singh Deeks of my community in Rockford
and I sort of like you know had them
improv this talking about their lives
bumping into each other sort of thing is
very slacker esque on that day it
filmmaking mattered more to me than
skateboarding and then you know I kept
making skate videos and then I you know
my next film that I did you know I cared
more about filmmaking I don't know that
man Serena she had no you are I mean
whenever you take on a project whether
it's having a YouTube channel or doing a
documentary it takes over your life and
so many ways like you basically have no
free time this is pretty much what
you're doing for a good chunk of time so
was there a point where you said you
know what I think that I'm gonna put
skateboarding on the back burner and to
me making this film is like everything
and I need to do it for me
I mean skateboarding I feel like it
wasn't ever that choice it was there was
never that fork in the road I was 24
when I started doing this film I really
wanted to explore these themes of family
and violence in childhood so I went
around the country and interviewed
skateboarders from all over the place
you know it confirmed my belief that
there's a lot of patterns in the
community and then a year in I met Kiera
and I was like oh this person hasn't
processed it in the ways that other
people have like later in the
documentary zach is like oh yeah of
course my father you know beat me I feel
like most people had where brushed it
off like that you know there's something
that had hardened over the softness that
Kier still held on to and that's why I
saw myself in Kiera you know and Kiera
is willing to do the work of processing
it you know to not just you know brush
it off to to make it you know something
that that mattered to him and that he
wanted to change yeah absolutely he was
incredibly open and I really appreciate
that and speaking of which and Zach I
think there was one scene early on in
the film where as that kind of looked at
you and he might have been smoking or
doing something he said are you
film this and then he says you know what
you can pretty much film whatever you
want so how do you earn that level of
trust with someone even someone who's a
friend I mean this thing can shape
someone in any way they want it to in
the editing room so had mama do you earn
that level of trust I think it was just
a five year long conversation about
representation that was one of many
moments both on and off camera where you
know I mean we talked about what was
gonna go in the film how they felt about
what we had captured so far and
sometimes they were you know light in
funny like that weed smoking moment but
other times it was like Zak how do you
feel about me having filmed you ran run
off to Denver how do you feel about you
sort of abandoning your son you know I
mean it so they understood that that I
was checking in that I cared and I told
them a couple years before we finished
the film that they're gonna get a chance
to see the film before it was picture
left and weigh in so I'm wondering when
you started actually filming videos in
general whether they were skateboarding
videos or whatever what when was the
like the first time you picked up a
camera 14 maybe yeah so pre DSLR I guess
we do sell our yeah I mean it was still
mini DV tape was the height of was the
height of Technology at the time and
then soon after I think like DVD like
dude you're recording the DVD came and
then recording the hard drive cameras
came so I believe initially you weren't
intending to put yourself in the film I
mean and I can see why a lot of people
have sort of their own take on that it
definitely works absolutely works that
you're in the film I think you said that
at some point your editor and you sat
down and you edited all three stories
separately just to see if they worked
can you talk about how that worked yeah
I met Josh last year editing a different
project and I convinced him to come on
to consult it first because he didn't
have time to edit fully and he told me
she tried editing every story on its own
to get it working and so I did that and
on the first try with Kiera and Zach
stories it was like okay we have a film
here for sure
get into Sundance and I was like what
his I had as you know that was the first
time someone had told me that and then
from my story it was like we're not sure
how this is gonna work we'll figure it
out later so we will sack and cares
stories together and then you know
ultimately it was it was finding it was
sort of characterizing the camera as the
character to ultimately lead up to the
mom interview and how was that to know
that it could go to Sundance and beyond
I mean most people hope for that and
they don't actually get it but then
you're filming this incredibly personal
story for all parties involved and to
know that oh my gosh like this is
happening because I wasn't doing it for
some Manson I mean there's a large part
of me that wasn't doing it just to make
a film it was so important to me that I
just would have wanted to do it and I
mean the goal is to try to get it seem
very widely so that it can make a
difference
I mean Sundance was great for that
purpose but I you know I'm very much a
realist and I'm just like and I'm very
much live in the moment I mean I'm still
sort of waiting waiting to sort of wake
up you know Oh none of that happened of
course yeah the last nine months was
just a dream so I think that you'd sit
in a Q&A or maybe this was someone else
that what's effective about mining the
gap is also what's not being said is
there anything you want to talk about
regarding that in terms of some of the
things you just show and some of the
things you leave out and and the
audience can kind of like fill in the
gaps in terms of and no pun intended but
you know just like what's actually
happening or some of the emptiness
around the lives of the skateboarders
yeah I think is that first year those
interviews were really on the nose you
know and that first assembly cut was
very much just like people barely really
like really directly talking about abuse
and violence it was just you know really
hard to watch and for many reasons and
then once it became more about a story
of Zach and Cara growing up and
these issues of you know abuse and
trauma coming out organically as
obstacles through their growing up I
think you know then it became a lot more
emotionally grappling you know
it'll-it'll does a lot and I think that
ultimately that's how we were able to
fit so many themes that are in the film
you know race class gender relations
masculinity because you know if you
really look at the mechanics of the
story there's really just a one-two
punch for some of these themes like for
a race for example you know there's
really three moments to deal with race
in the film but it says everything you
need to know about how this affects care
right can you talk about the types of
filming when let's say you want the
subjects to pretend that the camera was
not there and then filming where you do
want the subjects to look straight at
the camera how did you balance that or
was that not even conscious it was just
you were filming I wasn't really
conscious I mean I certainly adhered to
Verte you know the school of Verte which
is that you know you just hang out and
something happens you start filming you
know for me I feel like I watched a lot
of Verte films that showed how the
camera affected the story and like you
felt the presence of the camera there's
something actually more truthful to that
so you know I think that's why we left
in moments like Zach asking me like you
know do you want me to pretend like the
cameras not there or what because it
just yeah sort of nods to the fact that
yeah we're both constructing it and you
know we're filming things and the camera
might affect their how they're acting
but you can't always do that that would
be exhausting you know so there's
there's more truth to that I think we
asked some of our viewers questions
ahead of time we just let them know that
it was a documentary and we didn't tell
them too much but they had some
questions and they wanted to know first
off a viewer asked his name is zombie
dude 64
yes um he and I'm assuming is he I
haven't looked at his account so what
are your tips on finding screenings for
the film how was that finding screenings
like feedbacks user yeah how did you
arrange screenings award was it all
festival submissions and that's how oh I
see well I mean getting into Sundance
positions you really well for festivals
to come to you um a friend of mine
Stephen Elliott he's a filmmaker who did
this journalistic piece about film fest
fees you should google it I mean it's
really telling about you know sort of
the behind the curtains look of how
films get accepted into festivals and
the whole like her economy behind that
and there's unfairness there but it's
it's like you know I think it speaks to
being a filmmaker who's independent
making their first film and having to
learn how to play the game while also
learning the rules of the game at the
same time and it can be really
frustrating but I think you know these
things always change I don't know I mean
maybe the night the next film I make
will be distributed in a different way
I'll have to apply more but for the most
part we got into Sundance won an award
and basically every fest we've gotten
into is asked for our film and you know
I mean it's not like automatic either a
lot of films still a lot of festivals so
reject us it's just that they want to
come to us and ask for a screener at
what point did the film become movie
about fathers did you I think you said
you just set out to just fill that out I
was set out to be like that
you know I asked every skateboarder
about that so yeah I mean I was sort of
built in thematically at the beginning
all the themes are built into matically
it's just that the way that the themes
were told shifted over time I don't know
if I'll keep this part in I know the
interviewer is not supposed to reveal
too much but having grown up without a
father I had like one phone conversation
with him that was it I noticed looking
back on my life that every friend I had
they had a missing parent and then I had
this connection with them and I didn't
even realize that consciously is that
something that maybe you saw
with the film that a lot of the people
that bonded were able to bond in a way
that was there was stuff not being said
but because they'd had maybe a missing
link so to speak yeah I think heartache
really finds affinity with heartache I
certainly felt that way you know his
friends with mostly people who knew some
deep level of pain and I enjoyed being
around them because it made me feel less
alone in my situation you know otherwise
you know I think when I was hanging
around people that maybe were more like
white bread or vanilla with their
situations at home it did make me feel a
little less than and made me feel bad
about myself even though it wasn't my
own fault you know when your kid you
can't help that so hanging out with
people that shared my pain ultimately
yeah it was it was like an ad-hoc family
all of its own I used to dread going to
friends houses that would have like the
big family dinner because I wasn't used
to that and so it was so foreign to me
and like to know like okay well you have
to wait for you know someone so to speak
for you know just these unwritten rules
so yeah it seemed very weird and you're
like you're I mean what it does though
like it sort of enlightens you to the
constructedness of these things and
ultimately to everything and maybe this
is a symptom because I went to school
for English and it was more like theory
and criticism but my big takeaway is
like everything is constructed and we
can deconstruct everything and so I
don't know I mean I feel like I was
primed for that in the situations
growing up where yeah I just felt like I
was code-switching
I had to you know I felt like an
outsider but him that I was performing
in order to fit in how many years were
you making the film like when did you
begin and then when was it the final
edit was about 24 when I began filming I
was editing all along the way in my
bedroom we got funding late 2016 and
then you know we started our search for
an editor by that point I had you know
pretty decent rough cut I was like we're
gonna be paying someone $2,500 a week
they better be good but the problem is
in documentary at least like the really
good editors are both like a year or two
in advance it was really lucky that I
met Josh working in other crowd
he looked at the rough cut and he agreed
to come on to consult and then he had a
few months for you to jump in with me so
yeah that was sort of the big picture
process of crafting the film it wasn't
till the last few months that I dug into
our Kyle footage and you know built up
the sense of you know this is just the
skate video that turned into something
else
and even with Kiera I didn't know him
growing up you know accidentally filmed
a clip of him fighting Ida source a lot
of his footage from other people there
were more his age because he's 7 or 8
years younger than me Zack I had more
footage up because we actually were
closer in age we had another you were
right in and what's the viewers name his
name is John de Mol ooh and I'm sorry
John if I'm saying your name incorrectly
so he asked how do you know when you
really have a story to tell and why do
you choose to tell it so at what point
did you know okay this is taking shape
this is more than just interviews about
family and and what and why did you go
ahead to take the final leap and find an
editor that cost you know I think it was
I think I was ready to take the plunge
when I did a fellowship with car
tempering and watched a lot of Veritate
films and just trusted the process of
you know these characters lives they're
gonna lead I mean it's all about casting
to you know I saw him here this
opportunity to you know captures his
internal transformation and processing
both his father and it's raised growing
up for Zack it was pretty clear that he
was gonna have some issues with becoming
a young father like he wasn't quite
ready for it
you know our second shooting we did
together with Zack I went into the
hospital Nina was getting induced for
pregnancy because she was late they
botched her epidurals she flatlined was
very traumatic for her we did a long
interview with her afterwards I mean
yeah that was the beginning of it and I
was like okay this is this is gonna be I
fell
did you tell your subjects and I know
they were really more like friends but
that whatever you filmed would end up in
the movie or did you allow them I know
you said it the rough cut everybody got
to see it before it was like finally
sort of released but was that something
along the way that you kind of said like
if you don't like it I'll take it out or
everything I film is going to end up
here no I mean it was a five-year
conversation about what was going to be
in the film or not you know and it was
like I mean there was never once where
they were like don't put this in the
film except for when we were dealing
with Nina and what she wanted to the
film in terms of her relationship with
Zach and the abuse and that was out of a
desire to make the relationship work
right and in my head I was like well she
could change your mind you know like
this relationship was really fickle I
don't ultimately if she sees you know
the fine cut and doesn't want this
aspect of the film in you know we gotta
respect her wishes
I mean there's a famous story about
Kristin Johnson who did camera person
she worked on a film for two years
following these Afghani woman and as the
end of the process she showed them the
film and one of them didn't want to be
in the film at all and so you know it
was like two three years of work just
not down the drain but that she
ethically had to put aside and that
ultimately made her think about why what
am i doing documenting these lives and
that led to camera person yeah it's a
really fine line because you have to at
some point put put your foot down and
say well this is still my project but
then it's also someone's life and
someone's legacy you know people stuff
to you know go about their lives and
people will recognize them from the film
so I mean there's a power dynamic at
work that's so different from journalism
you know journalism you go and you get
some interview bites and then you leave
we're asking for years worth of
vulnerability and representation from
these people and you know it'd be one
thing if this film were about you know
Anthony Weiner
he's a lot more power than Nina does
Nina especially in this group is the
most vulnerable she doesn't have the
communal and friend support that Kyra
and Zach have and she's a woman I mean
there's the everything is sort of
stacked against her in the situation so
you know especially her I had to listen
to and yeah I mean I I lost sleep
thinking like what if she doesn't want
this to happen and but ultimately
everyone watched the film and they were
like you got it like he captured it you
know now the film is going to be
released is it August 17th it releases
August 17th on Hulu it'll be in theaters
several across the country and then a
broadcast on POV and 2019 so how does
that feel is Machain Jing's a lot in so
many ways in terms of the reach people
knowing everybody's story how does that
feel
I don't know I I think I'm like
dissociating right now because it's like
I mean that's a coping mechanism I
learned when I was growing up but you
know I think you know the way that
handle stress is I recognize what I can
and can't control and I've literally no
control over how what the film is gonna
do so I'm eager I'm eager to see what
its gonna do but I'm not sure I feel
much yet I think probably you know 11:59
on August 16th I'm gonna feel
nervousness but yeah right now I'm just
like you know what's for dinner
I can tweet about it yeah exactly okay
that's the new coping mechanism yeah
exactly
well I'm sure that people that have been
in a similar situation are going to
definitely resonate with the film and
maybe it'll bring up some old stuff but
I think it's you know I just seeing it I
still was thinking about the next
morning and you know I'm seeing people
that are a total different generation
than myself but seeing them go through
the exact same things that I went
through so I think that for a lot of
people it's going to be healing in some
way it may bring up some old stuff but I
think it's really important something
that um you know when we showed Nina the
vine cut she relived the relationship
with Zach
they'd been split up for over a year at
that point but you know she fell back in
love with them miss charisma
and she was also hurt by him again we
had to process that with her afterwards
and her feelings
there was one screening that was at a
college in the spring that she came out
to and there is a domestic violence
shelter there with a booth that also
drew out some people from their
community and there are these women who
were twice her age who were saying like
you know that your relationship with
zach reminds me of my relationship with
my husband you were so brave for getting
out now
you know you're so brave for telling
your story I could just see it as like
all these women were pouring their
hearts out to her that you know was
realizing her story is bigger than her
own right husband I mean I've dozens of
stories like that where there's just
been these really personal effects and
people that is gonna translate I think
to them being a different father you
know them you know being a different
person emotionally it's been pretty
amazing so far and I hope it continues
to have that impact we have another
question that came in it's much more
lighthearted and what's the user name
his name is nafisa Mustapha okay I'm
just hoping for like another disease
commented before he's been great in he
writes what would your advice be to
aspiring filmmakers so let's suppose
somebody's 14 again but not with a mini
DV this time they have 4k or you know
they have just an amazing sort of camera
that they're doing for the love you know
when I was growing up in Rockford being
a filmmaker it was just such a realistic
thing I was just doing it for the love
right
I was emulating things it would felt
good to be creative but in terms of like
making in terms of making a film
you know these things take years so like
don't pick something that you're not
truly passionate about pick something
that you care about more than just
making a film about and I think everyone
because of their personal experience
because of where they come from
because of the way they think everyone
has at least one story with them
themselves that only they can tell and
nobody else can tell I think people
should honor and respect that for
themselves and I don't just mean making
a personal film about themselves that
you know I mean it's just that we you
know we really need to sort of have
understanding across many different
aisles and lines that seem a little bit
more to highlighted these days you know
lines of division absolutely what did
she use to film the movie with from the
mini DV 2 there were other shots that
definitely weren't mini DV there were I
mean all that stuff I don't really I
considered all that stuff archival but
so filming it with three different DSLRs
and c300 did you outline the documentary
or did you have any kind of story
structure to it yes it started out in
the probably I've done like 40 grant
applications in those years and got
rejected for 39 of them 38 of them input
like grant applications a spurt either
treatment or you know or a synopsis or
something right and then as I got deeper
in the editing I put scenes and post-it
notes and you know put them on my wall I
kept a very detailed blog that while I
was shooting and that comes from me
working in the camera Department for
money to pay rent you know and then in
the final year I moved to a online
whiteboard that Josh Altman turned me on
to called real-time board it's a lot
easier than you know like writing and
post-it notes and sticky notes get
unsticky and they fall and it's all
digital and it's online and it can you
know share between different users and
you can just instantly duplicate the
whole thing and then rearrange stuff so
yeah there's several different versions
of you know both written treatments and
and scene outlines in the end what do
you want people to gain from the film I
mean there's so many themes as you said
to this film and in so many takeaways
it's about family
you know fatherhood breaking out of a
little town or deciding to stay I mean
there's so many parts to it
life moves really fast you know we turn
we go we go into our 20s and we get a
job a career family maybe then we turn
30 all of a sudden we get old but then
it's like we also have experience we
often experience adolescence as a time
where our emotions are not taken
seriously you know they're brushed off
is like oh just grow up or oh you're
being so emotional and there's all these
epithets that sort of you know
unconsciously tell us like oh no we need
to grow up we need to grow up but in
fact that time about it less adolescence
it's just such a soft time such a
malleable time and it just informs who
we become so much even in the little
things like getting our first job we're
talking about her father for the first
time with a with a trusted friend that
stuff really matters and I think we
should give it the respect in the
analysis that it deserves I think it'll
help us understand ourselves as adults I
don't know I mean also I mean there's
millions then we were talking about this
off-camera but there's millions of Zak
and cures out there and not all of them
happened to skateboard you know this
isn't this is these are issues that I
think youth face across the board yeah
and I think too what's interesting is it
affects you even beyond 30 and that's
something that I think people don't
realize whether you're a parent or not
yeah I mean you can brush it off you can
sweep it underneath the rug but I mean
those seeds that are planted are gonna
grow